- Learning is so central to
everything human beings do.
Knowledge needs to be absorbed
by people who need it.
Knowledge is a great enabler.
This is what we are.
The mission of Open Learning
is to share knowledge.
We want to make sure that learning
isn't this thing we keep,
but people can take and
do something with it
for their lives, for their enjoyment,
for the fulfillment of their
ambitions, their dreams.
So we work with MIT faculty
and we bring content to the world.
We are doing research on the science
of learning about how to actually teach,
regardless of whether
you're online or in person.
How do memories form?
How do neurons work?
How does context impact our learning?
What we have is a very,
very rich community,
rich in terms of talent,
rich in terms of diversity of thought,
diversity of background,
diversity of purpose,
that's a glorious thing.
Open Learning's values have a
lot to do with the word open.
We have to open education.
we have to open learning.
MIT's vision is that
learning has to be free
and liberated in the sense
that anyone can access it.
It's got to be efficient
so people can access it
in a way that's most effective.
Some of those things you
can do better online.
And some things like coaching or mentoring
you can do better in person.
The pandemic has taught us
that the half-life of knowledge
is even shorter than it was before.
Jobs are changing, media has changed.
Entire industries have changed.
That means that human beings
are going to have to transform themselves.
And the oxygen for that is learning.
There's so much we don't know
and so much we can do better.
So I think this is the beginning
of an incredible journey.
(gentle music)